This video is brought to you by VidIQ, the
chrome extension designed to help you get
more views in less in time.
With The Nun having only just come out, many
horror fans are already looking forward to
the next installment in what has become known
as The Conjuring Universe.
In this video I’ll be discussing what’s
in the pipeline and could be in the pipeline
in terms of future films.
Right now, at the time this video goes up,
there are already three Conjuring films being
developed.
First, we’ve got a third Annabelle movie,
which will be a sequel to The Conjuring films,
where Annabelle is locked up in the room of
cursed objects in the Warren home and starts
to interact with the other objects to create
mayhem.
However, the line that separates the mainline
Conjuring films from the spin-offs so far
is that The Conjuring films feature Ed and
Lorraine Warren, while the spin-offs do not.
But with this movie taking place in the Warren
home, wouldn’t that make it a mainline Conjuring
film?
Here’s how I think it will go down.
In the first film, The Conjuring, we see Ed
and Lorraine’s daughter Judy, sneak into
the room and she is reprimanded for it.
Then later on in the movie she wakes up in
the middle of the night to find the door,
which has like 100 locks on it by the way,
ajar with the Annabelle doll missing from
it’s case.
"Dad?"
And then a creepy lady is combing Annabelle’s
hair in the rocking chair, and then this happens.
...but when Ed checks things out, everything
is in order.
We don’t really know what happens to Annabelle
after that because the first two Annabelle
movies are prequels that take place before
The Conjuring and we only really spot Annabelle
in the case at the end of The Conjuring 2.
So my guess is that Annabelle 3 will take
place while The Warrens are away on another
case, perhaps this takes place at the same
time as The Conjuring 3, and the film will
focus on Judy or the Nanny who takes care
of her as horrors start to take place around
the house.
With Ed and Lorraine not there to help, Judy
may have to take on this entity on her own.
She’s also a teenager now, so that comes
with its own set of problems, and maybe to
defeat the spirit possessing the Annabelle
doll, Judy has to have her own spiritual awakening
as a medium.
After Annabelle 3, the next movie in the franchise
is The Crooked Man.
We don’t know anything about this one yet,
but like the other initial spin-offs, Annabelle
and The Nun, The Crooked Man will most likely
be an origin story for the entity that spooks
on the Hodgson family in The Conjuring 2.
However, it’s not entirely clear if The
Crooked Man is just another form of Valak,
or if he’s his own entity that Valak takes
control of.
At the end of The Conjuring 2, it is The Crooked
Man children’s toy that Ed puts into the
room of cursed objects, which kind of suggests
that it was Valak, but now that The Crooked
Man is getting his own movie, we’ll have
to see if that holds true.
The last film that is currently being produced
is The Conjuring 3, which will obviously be
based off of one of The Warrens’ published
cases.
But we’re not here to talk about The Conjuring
3, we’re here to talk about future spin-offs.
What might be in store?
Well in 2016 there was a short film competition
known as The My Annabelle Creation Contest,
where filmmakers were challenged to make their
own Conjuring Universe film.
The winner was an entry by a filmmaker named
Julian Terry, about a girl in the hospital
after undergoing some eye procedure and the
demonic nurse that haunts her.
No, I’m not gonna show the whole thing because
I don’t want anyone getting sued.
Mostly me.
I don’t want myself getting sued, but it
seems to be a likely conclusion that The Nurse
will be joining the lineup of bad guys in
The Conjuring universe sometime in the early
2020s.
Later in the real-life Warrens’ careers,
they took on a couple of disciples, Dave Considine
and John Zaffis, who went on to have careers
as media personalities… excuse me, Demonologists,
of their own.
Zaffis is actually the nephew of The Warren
couple.
He has his own museum of paranormal objects
and you can read about some of them on his
website.
Personally, I could see Simon, a supposedly
haunted puppet, being the subject of a future
Conjuring film, given James Wan’s affinity
for creepy puppets, so much so that his Twitter
handle is @creepypuppet.
The family who owned Simon claims their young
son would tell them that the puppet talked
to him, and one day the mother walked into
his room to see the puppet’s mouth moving
on it’s own.
Other notable objects that I could see getting
their own movies include a clown antique that
causes extreme discomfort for those who touch
it; Marionettes that have been blamed for
causing bizarre dreams; Mr. Sinister, an ornament
that has been said to cause unexplainable
odors and quote ‘a very bad tingling feeling’;
an Idol said to be cursed with black magic;
Mr. Bojo, a poppet accused of causing supernatural
occurences in a house and nightmares involving
a life-sized version of Mr. Bojo; and Island
Man, a three foot statue said to move around
the owners house on it’s own, talk to their
son, and supposedly move the son from room
to room.
So that leaves us with a ton of ideas for
possible movies in The Conjuring Universe.
Let me know in the comments which movie you’re
looking forward to the most, and which of
these other ideas you’d most like to see
get a movie of it’s own.
And if any of you are creators, or if you’re
uploading content to YouTube at all, you’re
not doing it right unless you have VidIQ.
VidIQ is the chrome extension that I used
to blow a video up to one-million views last
year when I only had about 6,000 subscribers.
VidIQ even has a video on their channel analysing
how I pulled it off.
All you have to do is download the VidIQ extension
and you get a ton of free features, like the
video scorecard which shows you how to optimize
a video to get the perfect SEO score, and
the new channel audit tool, which looks at
your channel and tells you exactly which videos
need work, and how to improve them.
Just go to VidIQ.com, link in description,
to get started.
And if you’re a fan of horror please remember
to like this video and subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, ring that deathbell
for notifications and I’ll see you in the
next one.
Assuming we both survive.